una volta mi sono chiusa fuori casa e
anziché chiamare il fabbro chiamato i
ladri
tantissimo
[Musica]
[Risate]
No non si è fatto in tempo ti posso
mettere del Gordon anal ovviamente
certo certo
[Risate]
drink analcolici buttate
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Ma manco con l'incantesimo
[Risate]
[Musica]
6 secondi
scusa
[Risate]
[Musica]
io non capisco la metti pausa che ha
detto ciauscolo
ho le lattine di coca-cola che piacciono
sembrano
[Musica]
convinta che mia madre al pomeriggio
e poi tenta quelli da Qualsiasi cosa
succeda davanti a un pubblico
No perché ricordo
[Risate]
[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
Ciao cara
[Applauso]
ciao Gu Ciao Carlo e Ciao altim più
bello
[Musica]
di ritardo
chiusa fuori casa e anziché chiamare il
fabbro chiamato i ladri
chiamiamola subito subito Ciao sono
Guglielmo Claudio
[Risate]
certo
casa sua
[Musica]
ho capito
potrebbe anche essere un porno
[Risate]
[Musica]
se ci fosse se ci sono problemi
È stato un piacere tempi comici
[Risate]
[Musica]
Tu che sei il mio più grande desiderio
Qual è il tuo regista preferito
[Risate]
[Musica]
[Applauso]
a quel punto di domanda
[Musica]
mi auguro una buona giornata e una
splendida amica Un bacione
[Risate]
in macchina acquisti
Martina
[Musica]
faceva così con la porta per 46
hai capito
[Musica]
e quindi niente diciamo imbarazzante
tantissimo ma noi non non potevamo non
farlo perché sennò esplodevamo perché
dovevamo stare fino al giorno dopo
Comunque avevamo le salviettine
cioccolata
alcolico questo Tommy Margherita
[Musica]